what's going on guys this is Rob and
Spider-Man 2 for the PS5 is out yes I
will be streaming it but what better way
to celebrate them to run over the most
powerful Spider-Man suits in the history
of Marvel Comics starting with the
Symbian suit because doesn't really seem
to be a reason to cover the OG red and
blue suit so in secret Wars number eight
this Cosmic drama saw Spider-Man's
trusty red and blue suit ripped apart
now in a bid to patch himself up Peter
stumbled upon what he believed was a
handy alien sewing machine but little
did he know it was far more Insidious in
fact inside was an alien symbiot
sneakily replicating the look of spider
woman's costume but with a spider emblem
influenced by null the symbiot God's
Sinister sigil now the perks of this new
suit there were a bunch it responded to
Peter's every thought it could morph its
appearance and the cherry on top no more
relying on manufactured web fluid this
thing could produce its own organic
webbing but as with all things that are
too good to be true there was a dark
side over time Spider-Man started to
feel drained and lethargic and then of
course suspecting that something was off
he sought insights from Reed Richards
and Johnny Storm the Revelation was
actually a pretty big one the suit was
not just some kind of a fabric it was an
alien trying to permanently bond with
Peter even taking his body out for
nocturnal Joy rides so desperate
Spider-Man turned to Mr Fantastic and
the Human Torch leveraging the Symbiotes
dual Achilles heels basically piercing
sound and Searing heat in order to get
rid of this thing but the symbiot
exhibiting a stalkerish persistence
ended up mimicking his classic attire
and then managed to bond with him again
now this pushed our hero to a dramatic
climax at Our Ladies of Saints Church
where he basically used the Bell Tower's
deafening Chimes to finally rid himself
of this thing but as comic lore would
have it the symbiot found another host
in the form of Eddie Brock giving birth
to the menacing guy that we know as
Venom here's the funny thing this was
not the end of Spider-Man's time with
the symbiot in fact Spider-Man had
multiple reunions with it during an
extraterrestrial mess involving the
X-Men and a symbiot infested brood and
then again when a poison version of The
Punisher decided that Spider-Man needed
an alien upgrade and who could forget
the epic showdown with the red Goblin
Peter had to make a temporary truce with
the Venom symbiot to face down that
monster who was basically the Green
Goblin with the Carnage symbiot it was
pretty dope but another fun little
tidbit here is that Matt gargan who was
at one point the Scorpion ended up
getting the Venom symbiot what's really
cool is during superior Spider-Man that
version of Spider-Man who we'll talk
about here in a second punched the jaw
off of Matt gargan and that's when he
realized Spider-Man had been pulling his
punches this entire time but coming up
next is bombastic bag Spider-Man this
suit made its appearance an Amazing
Spider-Man volume 1 issue number 258 and
while it's not the most powerful it's
probably the most fun imagine if you
will that our boy Peter Parker
Spider-Man was just having one of those
days the Parker luck it always strikes
again we're not talking about some kind
of like I forgot to study for my test no
no no we're talking about like I've lost
my super iconic symbiot suit and I need
a backup ASAP and so this took place in
the aftermath of the Venom symbiot Suit
Saga but you simply can't have
Spider-Man swinging around his underwear
right so enter the Fantastic for being
close friends with the team Peter
borrows one of their spare costumes but
there's a catch he doesn't have a mass
to go with it so what does our
improvising superhero do he throws on a
paper bag making sure nobody can see his
identity but here's where things get
even crazier the Human Torch never W to
miss a prank opportunity slaps a kick me
sign on Spider-Man's back and voila The
Amazing bagman Spider-Man is born now
you might be thinking Rob this is
hysterical it's a knee slapper probably
the funniest thing that I've ever heard
in the history of my life and I would
agree with that statement because I'm
probably the funniest person to ever
walk across the surface of the Earth but
what ends up going on here is the second
time that he becomes bombastic bagman
Spider-Man is after a particularly tough
situation which lands Peter in the
hospital and so black cat always the
playful one the flirty one she ends up
deciding to confiscate the suit and
guess what Peter's left with yep that
iconic paper bag mask once again it's
like these that remind us just how fun
and Whimsical the world of comics can be
sometimes in the midst of all the
serious battles and story lines we get
these Little Gems that make us chuckle
and appreciate the lighter side of
superhero life but getting back into our
main discussion about Ultra powerful
Spider-Man suits this brings us to the
Captain Universe suit originally
appearing in Amazing Spider-Man Volume 1
and issued 329 as part of the axe of
Vengeance story line so the Captain
Universe Persona is not unique to
Spider-Man but when Peter Parker merges
with this Cosmic entity it creates a
blend of power and responsibility on a
universal scale the unip power is a
really mysterious force in the Marvel
Universe and when it finds a host it
transforms them into Captain Universe
now why does Marvel call it the Enigma
Force or the unip power because they
just never bothered to explain what it
was so why not just call it the Enigma
Force right just lean into that laziness
Marvel but this is not simply just a new
look it's a massive power upgrade when
Spider-Man became the recipient of this
power due to a lab accident his usual
attire was replaced with the celestial
blue and white design of Captain
Universe the capabilities that came with
the unit power are nothing short of
astounding Spider-Man who's already
impressively powerful experienced a
surge in his strength and speed the
agility he was famous for Amplified but
it didn't stop there the unit power also
granted him the ability to fly a big
change for for our usually swinging hero
and a little bit of telekinesis just to
add the cherry on top that's right guys
Spider-Man with Cosmic level Powers
taking his role from a friendly
neighborhood Spider-Man to a defender on
a universal scale but during the events
of the second totem War Miles Morales
another beloved Spider-Man character was
also chosen by the unip power now this
further cements the idea that the spider
totem or the essence of the spider has a
pretty significant Cosmic resonance
attracting the unip power not once but
twice but moving on to our next one this
suit appeared in web of Spider-Man issue
number 100 this is the spider armor mark
one now when we think of Spider-Man we
often picture him dodging bullets using
his agility and the spider sense which
is like the only thing that lets him win
fights for the most part but when the
new enforcers turn the stakes up in New
York implying High Caliber firearms that
pose a significant threat even to
Spider-Man Peter realized he needed an
upgrade and so instead of relying solely
on his agility Peter tapped into his
scientific genius and so at Empire State
University where Peter spent a
significant amount of his time he
developed a pseudo metallic compound now
this was not simply just any material it
was specifically designed to be
resilient to the types of threats he was
facing the result the spider armor Mark
1 now this suit was a stark departure
from its regular look instead of the
flexible fabric that we become
accustomed to we get a shiny metall
looking Spider-Man that's ready to face
the enhanced Firepower of his folks now
while the spider armor provided him with
much needed protection against these
Firearms the added weight and the
rigidity of the suit meant that
Spider-Man simply couldn't move with his
usual speed and fluidity he was safer
yes but he was also slower like trums
when he went Ultra super saying did it
look cool yes was it practical no now as
with many inventions especially in the
high stakes world of superheroics the
spider armor Mark 1 basically had its
moment of Glory but it wasn't really
destined to last forever and during
during a confrontation the suit met its
end when it was exposed to acid which
basically compromised and then
ultimately destroyed its entire
structure but moving on to Amazing
Spider-Man Volume 1 issue number 425
this saw the introduction of the electr
proof suit now this is not just about a
change of style right I mean sure
Spider-Man looks cool sometimes you got
to shift stuff up but it's about
Spider-Man using his scientific knowhow
to tackle a specific problem headon and
so Electro who most of you guys know is
a guy who controls manipulates
electricity this guy has consistently
posed a significant threat not just to
Spider-Man but to Marvel as a whole fun
fact here Electro was probably one of
the most underutilized but most
dangerous villains in the entirety of
Marvel Comics but over the years his
power levels had fluctuated but there
have been instances where they've
skyrocketed putting not just Spider-Man
but all of New York at risk enter the
electr proof suit now when faced with an
especially amped up Electro Spider-Man
knew he had to level the playing field
but how do you counter such a volatile
power well the answer lies in rubber
insulation a material known to resist
and insulate against electric charges
and so Spider-Man fashioned a suit
entirely from this material ensuring
that Electro's electric blast would not
fry him on contact now the context of
this particular challenge was even more
intriguing because Spider-Man wasn't
going up against electric alone he was
actually teaming up with the X-Men which
just goes to show the scill of the
threat that they were facing but after
the battle Spider-Man ever the
perfectionist Revisited the design of
the electro proof suit with the initial
design while it was purely functional he
added some extra padding for increased
protection but beyond just the Practical
improvements he also added some styling
elements because Spider-Man's got to
look good and this ensured that even
when going up against a high voltage
villain Spider-Man would do it in style
but moving on to what is arguably the
most iconic Spider-Man suit of all time
debuting in Amazing Spider-Man Volume 1
issue number 529 we've got the iron
spider suit now as most of you guys know
of course Tony Stark the genius
billionaire philanthropist also known as
Iron Man designed a suit for Spider-Man
and this was all leading up to the
events of civil war with tensions rising
and that allegiances being tested Stark
took it upon himself to craft a new suit
for Peter Parker and it's not just any
suit right it was a blend of Stark's
Iron Man technology with Spider-Man's
needs the color palette of red and gold
immediately stands out reflecting
Stark's own Iron Man colors and his
narcissism an expectation that
everything be done according to how he
likes it but it wasn't just about looks
the suit was packed with a ridiculous
number of features some of which
Spider-Man never had access to Before
from radio transmission capabilities to
multiple Vision settings and while
ological sensors it was an absolute
Marvel of a suit and of course let's not
forget those baller arms which looked
absolutely amazing they just kind of
added this distinct Edge to Spider-Man's
silhouette yet the most iconic and
really intriguing feature might be the
suit's ability to change appearance
based on Peter's will this eliminated
the age-old problem for Superheroes Were
to stash the suit when it's not in use
but as with most gifts especially in the
world of superheroes this one came with
strings attached the suit was symbolic
of Peter's alignment with Stark during
Civil War a decision that would weigh
heavily on his concerns about Stark's
potential ulterior motives and then
hidden controls within the suit were not
unfounded and during a conflict between
the two Stark's ability to override the
suit's functions brought their
ideological Clash to the Forefront and
Peter turned on Iron Man joining Captain
America's side but moving on to Amazing
Spider-Man Volume 1 issue number 650
this gives us the stealth suit not to be
confused with the secret War suit now
this suit came by way of Spider-Man
facing off against the Hobgoblin but
instead of going for Brute Force he went
the science route drawing on his deep
knowledge he created the stealth suit
which was not just another costume it
again was a Marvel of Technology by
warping light and sound around it the
suit could essentially become invisible
making Spider-Man an even more elusive
target for his enemies but of course the
legacy of the suit didn't actually end
with Peter Parker and this is one of
those instances where we start getting
into suits that were used by people
other than Peter Parker a really good
example of this is that this suit was
used by Kane one of the Clones of Peter
Parker who would later utilize this suit
in his battle against the Spider Queen
but moving on to one of the more amazing
suits that Peter had while it's not
Ultra powerful in terms of all the crazy
stuff it can do is probably the most
useful suit this debuted in Future
Foundation issue number one this is
exactly what we call it the Future
Foundation soon so after the tragic
death of the Human Torch Johnny Storm
Spider-Man finds himself stepping into
basically Johnny Storm's place with the
Future Foundation now this team was
conceptualized by Reed Richards of the
Fantastic 4 and was built on the idea of
creating a better future for all now
it's not just about combating villains
it's also about Innovation science and
then pushing the boundaries of what's
possible and so given the Forward
Thinking nature of the Future Foundation
it's only fitting that Spider-Man get an
outfit upgrade to match now it's not
just any upgrade and in fact the future
foundation suit is constructed from
unstable molecules which is a
revolutionary material developed by Reed
Richards himself for those of you guys
who are unfamiliar unstable molecules
are a kind of dream fabric for
superheroes they adapt to the wearer's
specific needs meaning that Spider-Man a
hero known for his Dynamic movement and
Agility this suit would provide optimal
flexibility but the benefits don't stop
there the suit made from this material
can repair itself and it never gets
dirty and so imagine the time saved on
laundry alone but perhaps one of the
most intriguing features of this suit is
its ability to change appearance with
the future foundation's focus on
stability and evolution it's benefiting
that Spider-Man suit can basically shift
its look to fit different situations or
possibly just Peter's mood for the day
but moving on to fear itself issue
number seven this is yet another suit
designed for Spider-Man by Tony Stark
this took place during the serpent War
this is the serpent War suit now of
course during this time during fear
itself anyway the world was reeling from
the threat of Cole Boron and his
formidable group known as the worthy in
such Dire Straits Heroes often find
themselves needing to upgrade their
arsenals and who better to turn to than
Tony Stark the genius behind Iron Man
however this time Stark's Ingenuity is
complemented by the unparalleled
craftsmanship ship of the dwarves of
nadav just legendary for their skills
and weapon and arms forging the result
an armor made from uru metal a nearly
indestructible metal from the heart of a
Dying star the same material that makes
up Thor's hammer now the properties of
uru alone make this armor extraordinary
it's not just about physical durability
uru is actually known to be incredibly
receptive to enchantments which suggests
that the armor could potentially Harbor
Mystic or other world abilities
design-wise the fear itself suit
basically deviates from Spider-Man's
iconic look instead of the familiar red
and blue with black webbing the suit is
actually bathed in deep blues
accentuated by bright neon blue lines
that give it a more ethereal and
otherworldly appearance it's a visual
representation of the Grave threat that
they were facing at the time if we're
being honest with ourselves but one of
the more standout features of the suit
is its gauntlets equipped with razor
sharp blades now it's not just about
giving Spider-Man an Edge in
hand-to-hand combat all puns intended
it's a sign of the times the stakes were
actually so high during the serpent war
that even a typically non-lethal curo
like Spider-Man needed to be armed to
the teeth but as with many of the
powerful artifacts in the Marvel
Universe the fear itself suit ultimately
didn't last and under the direction of
Odin Iron Man ultimately had to destroy
the armor but moving on to Amazing
Spider-Man Volume 1 issue number 700
probably the Spider-Man suit that
everyone's been looking forward to this
is The Superior Spider-Man suit now when
Dr Octopus realized that his days were
numbered due to his failing Health he
devised a master plan that few would see
coming swapping bodies with Peter Parker
now with Parker seemingly dying in
Otto's ailen body the tables were turned
but a significant confrontation between
the two LED Peter to share his weight of
his experiences and responsibilities
with Dr Octopus the superior I
Spider-Man now this wasn't just a mere
memory transfer it was actually a
profound emotional connection a crash
course and great power and great
responsibility basically but moved by
these Revelations Otto made a surprising
vow he wouldn't just carry on as
Spider-Man he would become a better
version thus birthing The Superior
Spider-Man now in true Auto fashion he
immediately began overhauling
Spider-Man's modus operandi starting
with the costume the new design was
reflective of Otto's meticulous and
methodical nature the Classic Blue was
replaced with a more serious black and
there were numerous design tweaks from
the symbol on the back to the masks web
design functionality was also at the
Forefront of his mind the glass lenses
with a headsup display the retractable
Claws and talents and the spider arms
are all nods to Dr 's background in
technology and mechanics not to mention
a subtle homage to his Doc O days but
Auto didn't stop there paranoid about
another possible mind switch he
fortified the mask with carbonadium and
also added a Communications device
increasing the suit's utility however
with all Tales of identity and power the
ride was bumpy when Peter Parker
eventually returned to claim his body
and his identity he discarded the
entirety of the superior suit yet
circumstances drove Peter to modify and
then utilize it once more further
blowing the lines between the original
Spider-Man and the superior version now
later Otto would once again Dawn the
superior identity but this stent was B
basically fleeting culminating in an
identity crisis that saw superior
Spider-Man basically throwing the suit
in a trash can in San Francisco quite
literally but moving on to someone who
is not Peter Parker but is a much loved
Spider-Man in this Mythos we have the
suit that debuted in Spider-Man 2099
volume 3 issue number one this is the
all new all different Spider-Man 2099
suit now Miguel O'Hara which everybody
on the planet knows is Spider-Man 2099
was initially a byproduct of the
corporate driven future where the alamax
corporation held immense influence but
Miguel's transition to the present day
was Rife with challenges as he tried to
navigate a world vastly different from
his own and so after joining Parker
Industries an opportunity presented
itself a convergence of the advanced
technological knowledge of both Peter
and Miguel and so Peter always the
inventure the tinkerer and the guy who
just can't seem to catch a break saw the
potential in enhancing suit with the
modern ays Cutting Edge Tech which makes
no sense whatsoever because 2099 is more
technologically advanced than the
present day but the result was nothing
short of spectacular this new iteration
of Spider-Man 2099 and the suit that
came with it was a Marvel of
functionality and design its red glow
was not just for Aesthetics it could
actually change colors providing
tactical advantages in various
situations using unstable molecules
which is actually a major Focus point
for Spider-Man suits going forward
bonded to Kevlar and so the suit wasn't
simply just flashy it was built to last
it was a combination that provided
adaptability self-repair and immense
durability making Miguel ready for any
and all challenges that were expected
and unforeseen and so further augmenting
the suit's capabilities was the
integrated light bite material enhancing
Miguel's unique lighting ability but
Peter on top of all that adding
thrusters to the boots transformed this
glide into a full-fledged flight
capability offering Miguel an edge and
aerial combat and maneuverability not
only that there's the spider saucers
which I imagine or a blend of sleek
design and offensive capability but
integrated into the sleeves and gloves
they provide Miguel with ranged attack
options crucial in situations where
close combat might not be the best
approach lastly the onboard sensors
offer Miguel a full 360° awareness of
his surroundings and in that fast-paced
unpredictable world of 2099 and even the
modern era information was crucial and
so this addition ensured that Miguel
could actually make informed decisions
in a split second but moving on to
Amazing Spider-Man Volume 5 issue number
61 this was the threats and menaces suit
now the gray white and blue color scheme
is a departure from the traditional red
and blue that we're used to the glowing
yellow lines actually created a Sleek
modern and almost tron-esque look these
lines especially on the web shooters and
eyes not only add to the Aesthetics but
could also serve as indicators possibly
showing when the suit is using certain
functions or features now speed and
strength augmentation suggests that this
suit has some Advanced Tech embedded
think of it as Spider-Man with an extra
dose of adrenaline allowing him to push
past his usual limits now this provide
him with an edge in combat Chase
sequences and perhaps even in the
acrobatics that he's so famous for now
what was unique about this is that J
Jonah Jameson having a direct fee to to
Spider-Man's perception gives him a
firsthand view of Spider-Man's heroics
and it's a unique way for Jameson to
monitor Spider-Man potentially to
manipulate public opinion or simply
satisfy his own Curiosities but this
does raise questions about privacy and
control it essentially turn Spider-Man
into a live streaming superhero being
able to project Holograms can of course
be a GameChanger and Spider-Man can use
it to distract enemies create decoys or
even communicate now the remote control
feature could allow for manipulation
from a distance perhaps even by
individuals other than Peter like allies
or even Jameson himself but the addition
of two more exit ports could allow
Spider-Man to shoot different types of
webs simultaneously this could mean a
combination of sticky webs and impact
webs or even some new types designed
specifically for this suit again using
the unstable molecules this ensures
durability adaptability and resistance
to external factors making sure the suit
remained pristine and and functional no
matter what Spider-Man faced but going
on to Spider-Man Venom issue number one
this gave us the Spider-Man Beyond suit
now the impact thickening foam based
polymers are all fascinating in this
this indicates that the suit would have
a dynamic resistance to damage and so
imagine Spider-Man getting hit and
instead of the suit tearing or simply
getting damaged it actually thickens up
on impact to cushion and protect him now
this would be particularly beneficial
during combat situations or if he takes
a hard fall from high altitudes now the
bass being similar to the iconic red and
blue suit provides a bit of a nostalgic
touch the Triangular bars splitting the
sleeves at the shoulders provide a more
segmented and armored look suggesting
enhanced flexibility and movement but
the blue box on the back of the gloves
could be functional or purely aesthetic
but given Spider-Man's Tech History it's
easy to speculate that it could be a
control panel storage compartment or
just another Gadget feature but the
Triangular ends of the boots provide a
fresh take and this could potentially
Aid in aerodynamics or simply serve as a
new visual twist the shift of the logo
on the left of course reminisent of The
Sensational suit also gives it a unique
identity But continuing on with our list
of ridiculously powerful or at the very
least amazing suits we have The Uncanny
Spider-Man suit also known as the
Nightcrawler Spider-Man suit this of
course appeared an uncanny Spider-Man
number one now The Uncanny spider suit
which was worn by none other than
nightcrawl actually represents a melding
of two iconic Marvel characters
Spider-Man and Nightcrawler so with
Peter Parker providing an old Spider-Man
suit for Nightcrawler to use during fall
of X the result in design actually
reflects the unique attributes and
abilities of both characters the
predominant black color mirrors
Nightcrawler's own shadowy appearance
creating a perfect Synergy between the
wearer in the outfit the splashes of red
on the logo cuffs ankles and SES
highlight icon IC Spider-Man features
symbolizing the blend of these two
identities the Spider-Man logo though
retaining its classic form has an
altered structure extending its arms all
the way to the shoulders now the tail
inclusion on the logo provides a kind of
distinct uh nod to Nightcrawler's
appendage but Nightcrawler's unique
physique necessitates certain
alterations the suit features pointed
ears a nod to night crawler's elf-like
appearance the gloves accommodate his
three fingers and the boots are designed
for his two to making it ergonomic for
Kurt's Anatomy now one of the standout
features of Nightcrawler of course is
his tail and the suit design cleverly
integrates a space for it allowing for
its free movement without hindrance
giving n crawler the ability to stab
people in the face with it now given
Nightcrawler's acrobatic and
teleportation abilities the suit would
need to be highly flexible durable and
resistant to sudden changes in
temperature and so Nightcrawler's unique
senses might require the suit to have
adaptive lenses or facial coverage that
can adjust to varying light levels
especially since Kurt has a heightened
sensitivity to Bright Light but The
Uncanny Spider-Man suit epitomizes
collaboration and adaptability but with
that being said guys we're going to
bring this to an end if you guys want to
see a list of like alternate reality
Spider-Man suits because some of those
are pretty dope let me know down in the
comment section but thank you all for
watching and I will catch you all later
peace